what's going on there brooklyn nine nine
fans we are going to watch season one
episode 13. it's called a zip bet
guys full length watch alongs where you
sync up with the time coder over at our
patreon page yo we cover
so many other shows over there too homie
why is greg wearing this shirt
because i wanted to and because some
dinner plans got cancelled
for a celebration and i was like
well i'm already wearing the shirt
red means confidence what else do we say
prothom thanks for editing these things
for us buddy
the highlights always look so good and
appreciate all the support
is anything currently blocked from
brooklyn nine-nine are we clear we are
all clear as of today
as of the moment we just got a claim
released on another one
we'll see which other i mean there's
been a few that haven't gone unclaimed
yet
so watch out they haven't had their
chance yet it better not be this one
though because
people are looking forward to this
particular then you know we're going to
have trouble with this one yeah
got to got to all right guys let's see
what's in stores is a great fantastic
show subscribe and click notification
bells for more we've said everything all
right
let's roll that intro
[Music]
charles this is exciting medal of valor
i know for getting shot in the butt
[Music]
it is my great honor to present the
medal of valor
to detective charles boyle
[Applause]
argent peanut butter
[Applause]
oh no everyone's cheering way more for
sergeant peanut butter
oh my god charles is getting the same
metal as a horse
at least boyle was announced first
because the horse outranks him
sergeant peanut butter is pooping on the
stage oh
it's okay boyle it's not okay i know
you gotta get a vendetta out on that
horse gotta go make things square
how can i trust this guy's food reviews
now john
the bed ends today are you ready i was
born ready to lose the whole question
was are you ready to lose and you said
you were born that way
twist my words all you want okay i'm
winning this bet
whoever makes more felony arrests wins
what are the stakes and don't say money
because i know you're in debt if you
really knew anything about me you would
have said crushing debt and i'll bet
whatever cause there's no way i'm losing
what about your car oh oh oh
let's bet the car that car is your
superpower
thor would never wager's hammer neil
patrick harris would never wager a
showmanship
well what's the worst thing in the world
for you santiago being one of those
girls in jake's car
oh [ __ ] maybe she could be a girl in
jake's car
yeah foreshadowing game on game on
wow your handshake is quite firm i took
a seminar where
[Laughter]
i'd like everyone to join me at the bar
for drinks in honor of detective boyle
and his medal of valor ow
she does her own stunts you're looking
stoic today like a
wise old oak
up by one peralta anything you want to
say to your car before you
never see it again hey santiago do you
have any dietary restrictions that
medieval times should know about
[Laughter]
however you are colleagues and the
fallout from this bet has the potential
to put a strain on your professional
relationship
true i'm a terrible sport
because he's aware of it at least
captain you look no no
[Laughter]
rosa hey would you like to share a cup
of coffee with me sure that sounds great
isn't that like your fifth cup of coffee
today
the drowsiness from my pain meds i took
a double dose after the incident at the
ceremony
bring peanut butter forward what is it
what oh god no
step back please please don't tell me
oh who's the hero now peanut butter
peanut butter i thought he was gonna get
kicked personally
you're just trying to hurt me to
distract yourself from your own internal
pain
also you should use less conditioner
because this
is a flat mess wow
this happened to my dad when he got his
vasectomy unreversed
you get all relaxed you have no filter
and you just start dropping truth bombs
on everyone
oh that explains the elevator oh no
i'm worried you don't find me
interesting
he's gonna say something to the wrong
person and get himself punched sure i'd
love to see charles get punched
try again i will stop charles from
getting punched
correct ladies and gentlemen
i present carl watson who stole 3 000
santiago takes the lead with one minute
left oh no
that's right oh no oh he won i ran a
prostitution sting through vice and
arrested 30 guys for soliciting oh
no anywho 10 more for peralta except
your fate
never five four oh peralta
jake wins amy loses
oh yeah way to go
the mustang plenty of embarrassing to do
and only a few hours to do it in
oh wow wow let's see the bow
just like jenny gildenhorn why do i wish
you had braces
should we get you braces no that's too
much should we get you braces
do i really have to wear this all night
you know the rules the date starts now
and ends at midnight i decide what you
wear what you eat and where we go
and there is one more rule no matter
what happens you're not allowed to fall
in love with me
won't be a problem
[Laughter]
your medal was well deserved thank you
sir your breath is terrible
charles can i speak with you oh
hey baby hey
wife i'd like you to meet my wife sharon
oh so wonderful to meet you i've heard
such great things about you
and you your husband is a real hero if
you ask me he should have been up there
with detective boyle today
what for for saving my life
he means metaphorically if she doesn't
know
no no i was referring to how he threw
his body in an emotionally disturbed
criminal who was trying to kill me
he did what oh no oh you're back
in the field oh i've caught the problem
i am getting a text message
[Laughter]
oh no why is this the first time hearing
about this i thought i told you
remember when you were half asleep
watching the news and the babies were
crying and i said real love
hey baby i'm back in the field you want
something to eat and you were like what
and i was like you want something to eat
and
you said sure you are
a piece of work terence
damn oh no now i know that tonight
is boyle's big night
but let's forget about that completely
for a moment
comment on every terrible aspect of this
still wearing the metal huh yes i want
women to be impressed by me
boo hoo all right
i've contracted a youth choir to
serenade
[Music]
[Music]
this is awful all of this teasing this
elaborate date
somewhere down deep you like amy like
like you're like
okay that's straight up insanity
you live in your ex-wife's new
boyfriend's basement i'm not taking
advice from you
i'm ashamed of my living situation oh
i'm avoiding boyle and his truth bombs
i sometimes worry i'm gonna become you
oh he dove in front of those bullets
for me i can't be mean to him oh
captain holt told me not to let him get
hurt tonight so i'll keep him away from
you
oh have you seen rosa rosa died eight
years ago
santiago and i will be performing the
steerage jig from the film titanic
which we have prepared for in no way
shape or form
[Laughter]
do this do this pretty
one of our informants just called we've
been tracking the crew they left cargo
out of laguardia the ci knows where the
truck's unloaded so i need you to stake
out the drop site
all right fine but i'm taking santiago
with me as soon as we're done it's back
to the date
gina tagging no not even if it would
cure cancer
okay rosa's right there boyle oh
but captain's life was in danger i just
did what i had to do
it was an impulse decision oh i guess i
can understand
i have to apologize i want to assure you
that the call to put sergeant jeffords
back in the field wasn't a spur of the
moment
impulse decision it's been in the works
for
uh terry said it just
happened stopped you two need to get
your story straight
perhaps i should stop talking to your
wife
that's a good call no poor hold
the last lady i went out with burst into
tears when i told her i was in gemini
but been there yeah you guys suck that's
what i hear from everyone who's not a
gemini
sergeant jeffords was correct when he
said that his choice to go back in the
field that night was an
impulse decision he didn't even take the
time to stop and gear up
you didn't have your vest on
oh goodness i should have said that i
feel i may have made things worse wait
we love your husband he's a great cop we
will do anything to protect him
and you what the hell are you doing
lying to your wife
unless you want to end up moving into my
ex-wife's new boyfriend's basement with
me
you better man up don't you ever keep
anything from this beautiful woman again
i just didn't want you to worry baby i
am always going to worry about you
boil
keep on those pain meds my dude you ever
keep anything from me again
i will leave you for this short earnest
man and his ex-wife's new boyfriend
i know you're kidding but hercules is
actually a very good landlord
sometimes when they go on nice vacations
i'm allowed to use the hot tub
your stakeout bag is 98 nuts
i get snacky besides nuts are super
healthy they're like zero percent fat
the car's a piece of crap why do you
love it so much
i was two days out of the academy super
nervous saw this guy run out of a bodega
clutching a bunch of cash
finally catch him cuff him throw him up
against
that car huh turned out there was a for
sale sign in the window and it being the
best day of my life i bought it
thus began the debt crushing debt
you do know me only if you throw it
ready ready
oh no
i'm trying to catch it in your nose i
got it i got it i got it
all right let's hulk keep practicing i
found someone from the night shift to
relieve you on your stakeout
oh still make times square always gonna
want to stay
hold up on the relief team we're already
here plus i'm curious to see what
happens
oh so be honest if you'd won the bet
were you really gonna destroy my car
no i was gonna drive it so i could learn
stick
you wouldn't i would would have been
like
oh okay
here's our guys what's the play here
just follow my lead
give me the ring now give me some nuts
i'm snacky
excuse me sir oh we're kind of busy here
yeah my girlfriend here thinks we're
lost
no i know we're lost i think he's an
idiot
i was gonna propose to you and the
brooklyn bridge
say goodbye to the ring and everything
it represents oh
you son of a [ __ ] oh hey hey stop
yelling no one talks to susan like that
and you know what oh no
i'm sad y'all arresting me i got to say
i'm glad you're back together
[Laughter]
that's so stupid remember when i took
those bullets for you
okay let's do this i think you're sweet
i didn't know it was you
i jumped in front of those bullets i
didn't know who i was protecting
you've been extra nice to me because she
thought i'd risk my life for you but
i only did what every good cop would do
when you finally go out with me and you
will it'll be because i do things that
only charles boyle would do
actually i have a coat in here it's uh
it's like
it's actually i see it it's like it's
blue it's like right
i'm glad to see you two still work well
together despite that ridiculous bed
thanks me too and i appreciate you
turning down the relief team
i'm not sure they could have made that
bust the relief team
hmm sorry you lost so much money last
night
guess you can add it to your list of bad
dates no it still goes on the good day
list
you know cause we caught the bad guys
that's very mature of you well i am a
very mature man
package for amy santiago that's me
special delivery from
jake peralta just say thanks for last
night oh no
oh no
no here we go yeah magic
mike so uh
i'll take this bullet for you what are
you doing
i thought aren't we all gonna no
dude loves to get naked what a shitty
show i didn't enjoy my time
here's all my criticisms of this episode
today
guys all right let's get it out of the
way so we can talk about all the good
stuff
criticism i don't have honey
oh what dude i thought you were gonna
pass
what are you doing oh my gosh oh crazy
let me
clear up my criticism
[Music]
i don't think i have it either oh dude
smoke this
oh quick sniff this man
put this in your veins
yeah man that was a good episode come on
it was a good character episode
honesty uncovering the truth themes
the art of good storytelling is all
present in this episode all centering
around
boyle boyle being the person to bring
out the truth within
you know it's like boyle is the most
obviously truthful in this episode and
then
you know we got uh terence saying you
know in line with his wife who we
finally meet
that she's real and then her and then we
also have
um uh you know jake learning the truth
within himself like he started maybe
maybe crushy crush crush
yeah on the hottest copy now
[Laughter]
that's likely to happen yeah yeah and uh
yeah that was great
it was like a really sweet sweet episode
it was boyle kicking ass left and right
with truth bombs man
yeah and the gen captain holt just like
totally nodded his
it's like they switched to the elevator
on a freaky friday or something like
that
it's so funny absolutely but yeah i love
how the resolve came with boyle stepping
in where it's like oh no normally boyle
is the one who creates the disaster but
because he was direct about it that was
cool and then even right down to
because i remember after he saved rosa
it became like oh maybe this is the
start of rosa actually starting to grow
affection for him
but really she's just been feeling
guilty this whole time
and uh well not just only feeling guilty
but that's like a
predominant feeling and so that's why
she's in such servitude to him
but i love that speech in the closet
where you do think like you kind of feel
like he's probably not gonna do what
she's worried he's gonna do just because
they're setting it up so much but i
don't know what he's gonna do
yeah and then when you find out what the
truth is and how he lays it down and
saying like no this i gotta be honest
with you i
can see why you're doing what you're
doing but
you know you're not going to go out with
that guy because you feel pressure too
you're going to go out with the real
boyle you're going to go out with me
because you like
me yeah yeah i'm going to show you all
the wonderful things about
myself not just i love that distinction
not just
any good officer but me yeah because it
starts off
where boyle's being you know publicly
embarrassed again
yeah but here i don't know man he i was
rooting for him the whole time
absolutely that was amazing that was
beautiful and then of course jakey and
peralti
i mean amy peralti
and amy amy going on their date
they have such good chemistry they do
you know they really do been building
this this whole time
yeah and that's the funny thing is like
when they it's like
i've sensed it and i felt it in the
little moments and stuff like that but
having that real
tender moment actually come around i was
like no i actually really do like the
two
yeah when they're vulnerable and they're
sweet together and like you want
it's it's funny it's like the best way
to orchestrate a moment like that is to
have us rooting for the moment
to get sweeter and more vulnerable and
then the way that they were able to
bring their sort of wits together to do
this you know little scene in order to
make the actual
bust i thought was was wonderful because
you know i mean
amy can uh you know get into the games
to some degree as well not as
obnoxiously as peralta does but it was
cool to see them yeah
both go with the rules it kind of
reminded me of a more sweet and
sentimental version of when like captain
hulk goes with the ruse and he's like my
wife was murdered
you know like really committing to it
and really matching peralta on his level
uh yeah i thought that was super fun in
a way a nice way to culminate that
true because like jake's doing all these
elaborate things all jakey style
which are which is really fun
um and i really enjoyed it but yeah that
like little moment when he
when he's on the stakeout with her and
he realizes like oh i just like
he's just spending time and bonding with
her you know that's why a lot of people
who date on the bachelor don't
last together because this thing's
elaborate
hijinks and throw nuts but really what
they need to do is know
like can we bond over the little things
and
yeah and they bond over you know just
hanging on the down time of a boring
steak a steak outside imagine can be
very dull and you're just bonding
together having fun
and then she's also really dedicated her
job just as much as he is so
you see that yeah that's part of what
makes a romantic chemistry work so well
is that the things they both really care
about they have in common which is being
damn fine
a cop uh and i i love that that was
i said and the comedy was just obviously
so good
so funny yeah funny ass episode yeah it
was like it was funny
everything was funny yeah really
hilarious and really heartfelt
best of both worlds man i couldn't have
said it better myself
john you you probably could don't don't
sell yourself short give me 10 minutes
all right you got your phone on you yeah
let's do this all right just make sure
it's off airplane mode so i could text
you
right yeah so i don't want to let you
back in
let the room you know be ready for your
influx of genius
it's gonna be good i think everything
was funny yeah everything was fun
at all it's a 22 minutes
we're going to cover that gina made me
laugh at one point
yeah man always good i think we got it
thank you for tuning in we nailed the
and on top of that we gave a
perfect review it was the most perfect
most compelling
we summed it up well we broke it down
and we sucked
some of our own jokes in here that might
make some people laugh too
oh man so i'm just saying like this is
just a perfect video
it is perfect it's a perfect video
perfect length
we nailed the video in every way except
for the fact that during some of the
license song moments you're probably not
going to hear it
you're not going to hear a slide on the
family stone we already deal with enough
crap with covering brooklyn we're going
to duck the audio on those
moments all right all right guys well
thank you
so much for being here thank you to
everyone who encouraged this show
that just fell into our world subscribe
click the notification bell hit the like
button leave your thoughts down below
this
must be a hallmark of an episode we'll
catch
you you and
you and you and you next week
and you take care of yourself thank you
you bye
yeah you gotta cut the camera john
[Music]